MIKE DAHLIN: So I'm Mike Dahlin.
I'm an engineer working
on Google Cloud Platform.
And I'd like to take a few
minutes to talk about some
of the things that makes
our cloud stand apart.
The common theme you're
going to hear today
is that we're built on Google.
This means that being an
engineer on this project
is a fun job.
To take-- to having a
great global network that
will go to the
ends of the earth,
will go even beyond
the ends of the earth,
put lasers down--
and fiber-- down
with where the
sharks are to ensure
that we have that great
global connectivity
that so many of our
products depend on.
So number nine.
Let's see if this will advance.
Free, fast
connections to Google.
So when you build on
Google's Cloud platform,
one of the great features you
get is the rest of Google.
We give you high performance,
low latency, high bandwidth,
and no charge connection
to other Google APIs.
Other Google services like Ad
Exchange, YouTube, Drive, Docs,
apps, the Maps API.
This makes Google a great
place to build real time
bidding, a great place to
build video processing,
where you can do your processing
and upload immediately
to YouTube, a great
place to build
productivity apps,
interactive apps,
collaborate and work
with Docs and Drive,
a great place to build
geolocated services.
So there's a wide range
of other Google properties
and Google services
that can make your cloud
applications better.
Number eight.
Google Scale.
So Google understands scale.
And when you build on
Google Cloud Platform,
you get to take advantage
of the technologies we've
built that allow us to
deliver services at scale.
Not to brag, but what you might
regard as a success disaster is
likely something that
we handle every day.
As an example of this,
we ran an experiment
where we set up on the cloud
platform a bunch of servers.
We put a load balancer in
front of those servers.
That load balancer is
the same infrastructure
that we use to deliver
our other services,
so it knows how to scale.
We then fired up a
bunch of clients.
And we just had them start
blasting at the server
as hard as they could.
They were delivering a
million requests per second.
So with no pre-warming,
no warning,
just turned on the load balancer
and fired up the clients.
Within four seconds, those
clients were ramped up.
They're firing their
million requests per second
at the server, and the load
balancer is handling it.
After about a minute,
there is a little bit
of an adjustment as
things rebalance.
That all steadies out.
Even during that time, you're
getting very good throughput.
That all steadies out.
And by two minutes, things
have gotten completely boring.
Right?
And the million requests
per second just continue on.
This entire experiment
cost less than $10.
That was prior to
the price drop,
so it would cost
even less today.
Which means that this
technology is something
that really anyone can have.
Now, not everyone
needs to handle
a million requests per second.
In fact, that's
fairly unusual to do.
The way to think of this as
an insurance policy, at least
for most applications.
You may not need a million
requests per second,
but you may not know exactly
what you're going to need.
And so what you can do is
build on Google Cloud Platform
and know that the infrastructure
is capable of handling whatever
you throw at it, whatever
your customers throw at you,
you've got an underlying
infrastructure
that knows how to scale.
An example of this,
we saw last year
at the Eurovision
song competition.
Our friends at Scalar
worked with Eurovision.
What they wanted-- so Eurosong,
if you're not familiar with it,
is one of the most popular
television events in the world.
Because if you don't
look at sporting events--
sporting events are very big.
But then behind sporting events,
this is really right up there.
They see about 125
million viewers each year.
It's a big event.
They decided last year to start
an app for a second screen
experience.
But they face this problem.
How many users are they
going to get from the app?
How much load are they
You've got 125 million viewers.
Are you going to see
100,000 users, a million
users, 10 million users?
It's hard to know ahead of time.
You're launching a
brand new feature.
Really hard to predict
what's going to happen.
So they took advantage of
the flexibility of the cloud
platform, the scalability
of the cloud platform,
to deal with the fact
that they had uncertainty
about what they were
going to need to do.
Because they're
on this platform,
they were able to deal
with, for example,
in one phase of the
competition, they
saw load spikes of about 5x
what they were originally
anticipating.
And that wasn't
really a problem.
They could just scale
up the extra capacity.
It took a couple
minutes, and then they're
serving everything
that they-- they were
able to handle that load.
By the finals, they were dealing
with 50,000 requests per second
and serving those requests
with a 99 percentile latency
of under 35 milliseconds.
So really great performance,
great scalability.
And they were able to
successfully deliver
this new application.
Let's go to number seven.
Google's Cloud is green.
So this might matter to you
because you're green too,
and you'd like to have
a cloud provider that
thinks about these things.
Nothing else that you don't have
to worry about making your data
center green.
Let Google worry
about these things.
Let Google worry about
being very efficient
and finding green
sources of energy.
Green is something that's
very deep in our values,
and it's something that
we've worked on and invested
heavily in over time.
As an example of that,
this upper right picture
is from the Ivan Pa
solar thermal plant
that just went online earlier
this year in the Mojave Desert.
Ivan Pa is a 392 megawatt
generating plant.
So that's enough green energy
to power over 100,000 homes
or dozens of 10
megawatt data centers.
Another example here, this
is one of the wind farms
that we source some of
our renewable energy from.
There's a bunch of these.
You can go to our website to
see more examples of that.
As just another data
point, Google as a company
has been carbon
neutral since 2007.
So something that's
deep in our values,
we think it's very important.
But being green is
all well and good,
but at the end of the
day, some people just
have green eye shades.
And my argument is
that this should
matter for the
accountants as well.
That by putting these types
of investments in place,
we're able to lower
our cost of energy.
We're able to insulate
ourselves from volatility
in energy prices.
We're able to insulate ourselves
from potential increases
in the cost of carbon over time.
And so this is the
type of thing that
has allowed us to
reduce our costs
and pass those
savings on to you,
as you saw earlier today
as we dropped our prices.
Let me give a concrete example
of how the accountants should
love a green cloud
as much as we do.
So what this graph shows is the
power utilization effectiveness
across Google's data centers,
across our entire fleet.
Shows that year by
year since 2008,
power utilization
effectiveness is
a measure of data
center efficiency.
What it measures is to
deliver one watt of power
to the compute
infrastructure, how many watts
do you need to actually
put into the data center.
So in 2013, our power
utilization effectiveness,
our PUE, was 1.12 over the year.
That meant that over 88% of the
energy that went into a data
center actually went to
the compute, the storage,
and the networks, the things
that you actually care about.
Less than 12% was
spread across cooling,
across electrical
transformation,
transmission losses,
even across keeping the
lights on in the data centers.
So this is a pretty
remarkable achievement.
If you look, for
example, in 2012,
that's the last
year I've got data,
the average across the
industry, the PUE was about 1.8.
So on average, in industries,
and probably those of you
that walk into a
typical data center,
the big crack units are running,
this is not too surprising,
on average almost half
of the electricity that
goes into a data center goes to
these other types of overheads.
Google is able to
drive that cost
down through really long
term investments and building
state of the art data centers,
has been able to drive
that down to 1.12, where
88% or better of the energy
is actually going
to what you want.
Number six.
Supercharged disks.
So physical disk
drives really haven't
changed much since the late
1950s when they were invented.
You've got some
spinning platters,
you've got an arm that
you move back and forth.
They're getting bigger, they're
not getting much faster.
Moore's law is great for
moving and storing electrons,
but it doesn't
really do much when
you need to move a piece
of metal to read your data.
And as disks have
gotten bigger, you
get fewer I/Os per gigabyte.
Your data becomes trapped
inside of these disks.
PD, Persistent Disk, is the disk
drive system, the block drive
system that we provide as
part of Compute Engine.
Instead of relying
directly on this kind
of ancient technology,
on the left,
it's built on
Colossus and Spanner.
Colossus and Spanner are two
of the large scale data storage
systems that we've built inside
of Google for storing lots
of data, spreading it
across a bunch of disks,
and reorganizing that data
for more efficient access.
As an example of what
you get by moving
from the old physical device
to our new virtual device,
if you take a two terabyte
physical hard drive
and compare it to a two terabyte
persistent disk, both of them
can get very good sequential
read and write bandwidth.
If you're not having to move the
metal, you can do pretty well.
But as soon as you start
having to move metal
to read your data, to do
random reads and random writes,
traditional disks
really fall down.
You can get dozens, maybe
75 read and write IOPS.
Whereas on PD, with this
ability to reorganize
the data for more
efficient access,
with this ability to paralyze
the access across large numbers
of underlying physical devices,
you can do 8 to 32 times
better.
So other advantages
of our PD device
virtualizing this old
technology, first of all,
you can move PD between
machines easily.
So you don't have to pull up the
disk and put it somewhere else.
You send a command, you hook
it up to another machine.
You can actually simultaneously
mount a PD device
across multiple
virtual machines.
So in this example, we've got a
web service, a bunch of clients
are accessing it, we've
got a load balancer that
spreads the load across a bunch
of Compute Engine front ends.
They're all sharing the
same backend storage
of all the data they're
actually serving.
This is nice because
it saves you money.
You only have to pay
for the data once
to store the data once.
And it also can simplify
your administration.
You do one update, and
all your different servers
can see that update.
You don't have to keep a
bunch of copies in sync.
Another nice thing
about PD is that there's
no separate charge for IOs.
This goes to the theme of trying
to give you a simple model
to think about pricing.
So we think this
makes sense that when
you buy a physical disk drive,
you get not just the platters,
but you also get the arms.
You don't have to buy
the arms separately.
We're going to do the
same thing with PD.
When you buy PD, when you
rent PD, you get the IOs.
There's not going to
be a separate charge
for actually using those arms.
This is both simpler
for you, but also
makes it easier to
predict your bills.
You don't have to try
to figure out, OK, I've
got a bunch of web servers.
How many IOs per month
are they going to do?
So you can predict what
your bill is going to be.
Instead, when you buy the
PD, you look at the size,
tells you what the price is
going to be and you're done.
Finally, just another
nice property of PD,
and there's a bunch of other's
you can go read more about it,
is that we get rid of
some of the limitations
of the underlying
physical devices.
So for example, if
you've got a big database
and you want to put 10
terabytes for your database
onto a single volume,
that's something
that we can accommodate.
No problem for us.
Number five.
Consistent performance.
Multi-tenancy is hard.
When you build a
shared infrastructure
and you want lots of
diverse applications
to use that infrastructure,
you have this challenge
of making sure that one
application doesn't interfere
with another application.
Google has lots of experience
dealing with this problem.
We've been running multi-tenant
data centers for a long time.
And we've built up a
reservoir of technologies
that we use internally, and
now we can use in our cloud,
to help provide that
type of isolation
to give you consistent
performance.
We've built cluster management
systems, and schedulers,
in Borg and Omega, that help us
provide this type of isolation.
As we just mentioned
in the earlier talk,
we've been really some of
the pioneers in containers
and contributed some
of those techniques
back to the open
source community
for isolating different
groups of Linux processes
and giving them
consistent performance.
We've been pushing the
boundaries of software defined
networking and taking
advantage of that flexibility
to improve the isolation
in our clusters
and across our clusters.
As I mentioned a
little bit ago, we've
built internally a big
collection of shared storage
systems.
Spanner and Dremel and Colossus.
And those systems
have been designed
to allow different applications
to take advantage of a shared
service, but get the consistent
performance that they need.
And then finally,
we've just built up
over the time operational
practice and tools.
We've got the tools to
monitor what's going on,
to react when we see
something that's not right,
and to fix those problems and
improve our systems over time.
And we've been doing that to get
better and better consistency,
both internally
and now externally.
We hear over and over
from our customers
that they value this
type of consistency.
This is one example
of one of the quotes,
but we hear this from a lot
of customers all the time.
And it's something we
take pride in and think
is a really important
thing to be delivering.
As an example of
the types of things
that we do to improve the
consistency of our service,
I just wanted to show
this very recent example.
What this graph
on the right shows
is what kind of
performance do you
get for the CoreMark benchmark
as you spin up two, four,
or eight CPU virtual
machines on a platform.
In the left hand side
of each pair of these
is what we've been
delivering until recently.
These are all-- these
are called violin graphs,
this is a violin graph.
And so the way to
read this is you could
look at one of these
clusters of points.
It says it's four CPUs.
And the thickness at any given
level is basically a histogram.
The number of samples,
the number of machines
out of the benchmarks
that we ran that
delivered this level
of performance.
Ideally what you'd see would
be perfectly flat, thin lines
for each of the configurations.
And we're pretty
good if you look
at our recent version
of the system.
So for example, if you
look at the four CPU case,
the vast majority of the
VMs that we've spun up
had an expected
level of performance.
But there was a little bit of a
tail and every once in a while,
we got an outlier going
one way or the other.
This is probably
not something you'd
notice unless you were looking
pretty carefully, running
a lot of VMs.
But it is something
that we detected.
One of our engineers
noticed this and thought,
this is not OK.
We want to have
consistent performance.
This engineer spent
several weeks, actually
a couple of months tracking
down what was going on.
Did a bunch of
statistical analysis,
found out when did you
get better than expected
performance, when
did you get worse
than expected performance.
Tracked it down, found an
issue in the Scheduler,
and was able to provide
a better Scheduler.
And that gives us the
performance shown on the right.
We're very nearly back to that
ideal of a perfectly flat,
thin line when we spin
up these machines.
That change has been
rolling out to our clusters
over the last couple
of weeks and will
continue to roll out
over the coming weeks.
And so if you've been happy with
the consistency of performance
that you've seen in
the past, it should
be getting even
better in the future.
Now, this may seem
like a small thing.
Right?
I mean, the vast majority
of the time in the past,
it was working just fine.
Those tails didn't
happen very often.
And a lot of people probably
wouldn't even notice them.
But if you ever tried to
debug a weird performance
anomaly in your system,
you've got enough problems
with your own code
without that underlying
system shifting underneath you.
Or even if you're just
trying to do something
as simple as predict the
number of virtual machines
that you need to serve
a given level of load,
you really want to know
what each of those machines
is going to deliver.
That's something
that we value, we've
learned how important this is.
We've got some great
engineers working
to make that better
and better over time.
Number four.
Security.
So this picture was taken
at one of our data centers
a couple years ago.
It was posted as a Street View.
It perhaps tipped our
hand a little bit more
than we intended about
how far away we're
willing to go-- sorry--
to improve our security.
But suffice it to say, we
take security very seriously.
We physically protect our sites
with fences, barriers, guards.
We have strict access control.
My badge will not get
me into a data center.
And we have video surveillance
with both human monitoring
and also programmatic
monitoring.
Programs that actually
analyze the video,
detect anomalies,
and raise alarms
so people can have a
look and figure out
what more needs to be done.
We do automatic
encryption at rest
across PD cloud
storage and Cloud SQL.
This is something that you don't
have to configure anything,
the data gets encrypted
automatically.
We provide secure communication
with both physical security
and encryption across
our various networks.
We have a growing list of
sort of certifications,
kind of attesting to the sorts
of things that we're doing.
Here are some of these.
But I think just broadly
the thing to understand
is that, again, high
security is something
that Google as a
whole depends on.
It's part of our values.
It's something that we
work on all the time.
We intend to lead and drive
security for the industry.
We depend on it for all
of our other products.
We provide it in Cloud, and
we take securing your data
as seriously as we
take securing our own.
Number three.
0 to 100 in 38.
So this graph is, again,
another violin graph.
In this case, showing the time
that it takes to start up VMs
that are part of various
sizes of clusters.
So we start up clusters
of 1, 10, 25, 50, 100 VMs.
And then what the
violin graph is showing
is the histogram of how long
it takes for each individual VM
to get started.
We run this trial a bunch of
times to get a distribution.
The histogram shows that.
So the first thing
you might notice
is that spinning up
a single VM is fast.
Looks like the first ones
are showing up-- typically
one will show up in 21 seconds.
In all of our experiments
they showed up
between 21, 22, and 23 seconds.
So the VMs come very quickly.
And that's from the
time that we say
go until you can
SSH into the VM.
The second thing
you're going to notice
is that spinning up a bunch of
VMs doesn't take much longer.
So in the case where we
kick off 100 VMs, spin them
all up at once,
again, we measure
how long until
individual VMs arrive.
And in this example,
some of the VMs
are showing up as quickly
as looks like 18 seconds.
All of them have arrived in all
of our trials in 38 seconds.
So you can spin up a bunch of
VMs, and it comes very quickly.
What this lets you do is
adjust to changing demands.
As the load on your
system changes,
the resources you're
using to serve that load
you can quickly move up to
match what you need to do.
It was this type of agility
that our friends at Scalar
used to help Eurovision meet
their demands for the Eurosong
contest that I talked
about earlier today.
Per minute.
So as some of you may know,
we have a sister business
that sells ads.
And a big part of what they
need to do to make that business
work is micro billing.
And so once again, we've
taken technology that
we've-- an institutional
experience,
and applied it to our Cloud
to improve our platform.
So in particular, we
offer per minute billing
with a 10 minute minimum for
our Compute Engine instances.
Now, this will both
save you money,
especially for very short
running instances, but any time
that you're running
an instance and it
doesn't take exactly
an hour worth of work.
So if your work takes a
little more or a little less
than a certain number
of hours, you're
going to save money with
this per minute billing.
What this graph shows is on
the x-axis, the number of hours
that a VM runs, on the y-axis,
the price that you get.
The cost that you
pay to run that VM.
And as you can see, being able
to pay for just what you're
using can actually result
in some pretty significant
savings.
Again, this gives you
more ability to one,
deal with changes in
demand, but also two,
take advantage of our scale.
So for example, if you're doing
a analysis of a big data set
on Compute Engine, so you're
spinning up a big Hadoop job,
rather than run on 100
machines for an hour,
run on 600 machines
and get the same answer
for the same price
in 10 minutes.
Finally, number one.
If per minute billing is--
renting our infrastructure
by the minute is cool,
renting it by the second
is even better.
And that's effectively
what you're
doing when you use
the BigQuery service.
What BigQuery does is it spreads
out analysis of your data
across hundreds or thousands
of machines without, of course,
you having to manually shard it.
We take care of all that.
It allows you to use a familiar
SQL-like query interface
to this data across
these massive data sets.
This graph shows-- this actually
comes from the Dremel paper
that we published
a couple years ago
to describe a lot of the core
techniques inside of BigQuery,
inside of Dremel at that time.
What it shows was that
they were able to do
an analysis of a
trillion row table, doing
a top-k query across
that trillion row table,
and by spreading out the
analysis of this trillion row
table across thousands
of nodes, they
were able to get their
answers in under a minute.
Now of course, we didn't
stop working on Dremel
when we published the paper.
We continued to
work on this system
and giving you new features
like the continuous queries that
were described earlier today.
So that you upload data, you
can keep streaming up uploads
continuously, and as soon
as the data hits BigQuery,
you can issue your request,
and now your queries
are going to return answers
reflecting that most
recent data.
So we develop these
technologies as part of Dremel.
Internally, it's a great tool.
And we're really happy that now
with BigQuery, you have access
to this technology as well.
So thanks for letting
me talk about some
of the things that make
the platform special.
We've been able to bring
you some neat things so far.
Things from sharks to scale,
consistency to security,
from green to the
rest of Google,
and I'm really excited to be
an engineer on this project
because I feel like we're
really just getting started.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]